this talk is a little bit hazardous
we're going to see some things that
might tickle your brain we're going to
look at some image
stressing although it won't be entirely
clear why they're distressing but we'll
talk about why and we'll also talk about
some things that we don't talk about and
all kinds of things tend to float
downriver when you open locks like that
so I want you to be here for it which
means if you can't be here for it then
take care of yourselves otherwise hi my
name is Oishi and I'm a senior software
engineer at github which has nothing
whatsoever to do with the talk you're
about to hear because today I want to
talk about a hobby I'm gonna share with
you some of what I've learned at the
intersection of computational
neuroscience and artificial intelligence
for years I've been fascinated by how
our bodies make experiences how we
perceive how this machinery of ours
results in qualitative sense and why our
experience is shaped in the way that
they are why do we feel exquisite joy
why do we suffer and I've also been
fascinated by AI which I think we all
have we're watching these little robots
become better and better at
approximating the tasks of our cognition
sometimes in unsettling ways and so
today I want to share with you some of
what I've learned some of it is solid
research and some of it is solid
speculation and all of it speaks to a
truth that I have come to believe but we
are computations and our worlds are
created on a computer that is ancient
and powerful beyond imagining so let's
begin part 1
hallucinations this person is Macario
Nieto and he has something to show us it
starts with these simple patterns
splotches of light and dark like images
from the first eyes and this is going to
give way into lines and colors curves
and more complex shapes we are diving
through the layers of the inception
image classifier and it seems that there
are whole worlds in here shaded multi
traumatic hatches the crystal and farm
fields in alien world
the cells of plants to understand where
these visuals are coming from let's take
a look inside the job of an image
classifier is to reshape its input which
is a bunch of pixels into its output
which is the probability distribution
the probability that the image contains
a cat the probability of a dog a person
a banana a toaster it performs this
reshaping through a series of
convolutional filters a convolutional
filter is basically Photoshop filters
each neuron in a convolutional layer has
a receptive field some chunk of the
previous layer that it's watching and
each convolutional layer applies a
filter specifically a filter is an image
kernel just a matrix of numbers where
each number represents the weight of an
input pixel so we multiply each of the
values in the receptive field by the
weights and we sum them together this
neurons output value now this filter is
learned during training and the same
filter is applied across all neurons in
a layer we feed the classifier labeled
image something where we know what's in
it and it outputs predictions and then
we math and figure out how wrong those
predictions were
and then we math again figuring out how
to change the filter in the direction
that would make them more correct this
process is a gradient descent
in deep dream we invert this so this
visualization is recursive we start out
with that photo of Miguel and then to
compute the next frame we feed the
current frame into the network we run it
through the networks many layers until
we activate the layer that we're
interested in and then we math how could
we adjust the input image to activate
this layer more and then we adjust the
image in that direction the term for
this is gradient ascent
so finally we scale the image up very
slightly before feeding it back to the
network this prevents Inception from
fixating on the same patterns in the
same places and it also creates this
really wild zooming effect so every
hundred frames we move to a deeper layer
or a layer to the side Inception it
turns out has quite a lot of layers and
they're not in a linear stack and that
gives us this so we started because
rudiments of light and shadow and deeper
we have this city of kodamas thing
happening and then shortly we're going
to enter the spider observation area in
which spiders observed you but it's okay
because the spiders are going to become
corgis and then the corgis are gonna
become the 70s later we have a space of
almost human eyes which are going to
become dog slugs and then dog slug birds
here there was an unfortunate
saxophonist teleporter accident and
finally down here we have entered fully
the flesh zones with a side of lizard so
when I first saw this I thought to
myself that it looked like nothing so
much as Donald Trump and I resolved to
never tell anyone that until I showed my
roommate this video and she said exactly
the same thing which I think has more to
do with the state of our neural networks
than this one I think the lizard
juxtaposition is really suggestive
but I do want you to notice and think
about what it means that all of this
flesh is so white so this is all yeah
it's pretty trippy isn't it what does
that mean what's it mean for something
to be trippy to figure that out let's
take a look inside ourselves meet Scully
Scully doesn't need all this craft we
just care about Scully as visual system
our visual system which starts here in
our retinas your retinas our retinas are
pretty weird so light comes in and it
immediately hits this membrane there's a
layer of ganglions after the membrane
which are not particularly sort of
receptive although some of them are a
little bit beneath them is a layer of
stuff that does important things and
then at the back of your retina are all
the photoreceptors rods and cones which
sends luminance and color so light comes
in and it winds its way through these
four layers of tissue it hits a
photoreceptor which gets excited and
that sense it's a signal out where
exactly so it sends it to a ganglion and
then the ganglion has to send it down
the optic nerve which is here it's like
routed right through the center of the
eye so our eyes are sensors that are
mounted backwards with the hole drilled
through the center thumb and it's all
kind of okay because we can patch it up
later in software so there's a couple of
other problems here one you have 120
million rods and six million cones in
your eye and you have about ten times to
your ganglions than that so there's a
significant mismatch in the carrying
capacity and the number of receptors and
- it gets worse because if you do the
calculations your optic nerve can carry
about ten megabits that's its bandwidth
so we're trying to push the signal from
this 100 megapixel camera
through a pipe that's slower than Wi-Fi
and our retinas do what you might do if
you're faced with such a problem they
compress so each ganglion has a
receptive field connects to about a
hundred photoreceptor cells these are
divided into a central disc in a
surrounding region Center and surround
so when there's no light on the entire
thing the ganglion doesn't fire and when
the whole field is illuminated
it fires weakly and then your ganglions
are divided kind of into two species one
species when only the surround is
illuminated and the center is dark it
fires very strongly and in the other
arrangement does not fire at all the
other half of your ganglions behaving
exactly the opposite way they fire
strongly when the center is bright and
the surround is dark so taken together
the behavior of these ganglions that are
intermixed constitutes an edge detection
filter we are doing processing even in
our eyeballs and that processing allows
us to bounce up temple the image from
our photoreceptors a hundred times while
retaining vitally important information
namely where the boundaries of objects
are so then the signal goes into the
brain it hits the optical chiasma where
the data streams from the left and right
eyes cross giving us 3d stereo vision
it's processed by the thalamus which is
a whole signal processing center kind of
a Union Station for your brain and all
men are things happen there amongst
other things your thalamus runs your
eyes autofocus something which you
probably noticed that you have but maybe
never noticed that you have each step of
the signal processing pathways
extracting a little something and that's
all before we get all the way back here
to the visual cortex so our visual
cortex is arranged into a stack of
neuronal layers the signal stays pretty
spatially coherent throughout these
layers and so there is some slice of
tissue in the back of your head that is
responsible for pulling faces out of
this part of your a visual field
more or less with the kind of slop that
we've come to expect from any neural
network biological or artificial each
neuron in the visual cortex has a
receptive field some chunk of the entire
visual field that it's looking at and
neurons in a given layer of the cortex
respond similarly to signals within
their receptive field and that operation
distributed over a layer of neurons
performs some sort of feature extraction
on the signal first we extract simple
features like patterns of light and dark
and colors and edges and then more
complex features like surfaces gradients
objects I is in motion it's no accident
that we see the same behavior in
Inception because convolutional neural
networks were designed after the
construction of our neural our visual
cortex so our visual cortex is of course
different from inception in many ways
inception is a straight shot through
one-pass
input/output our visual cortex however
contains feedback loops these pyramidal
neurons that connect deeper layers to
earlier ones these feedback loops let
the results of deeper layers inform the
behavior of previous layers so for
example we might turn up the gain of
edge detection along the boundary of
what has later been detected as an
object this lets our visual system adapt
and focus not optically but
attentionally it gives us the ability to
ruminate on visual input well before we
become consciously aware of it improving
our predictions over time you know this
feeling thinking you see one thing and
then realizing it's something else
so these loopback pyramidal cells in our
visual cortex they're covered in all
kinds of receptors and particularly
they're covered in serotonin receptors
different kinds of pyramidal cells
respond to certain and differently but
generally they find it exciting and
don't we all
you might be familiar with serotonin
from its starring role as the target of
typical antidepressants which are
serotonin reuptake inhibitors
when serotonin is released into the
brain they make it stick around longer
thereby treating depression some side
effects may occur most serotonin is
actually located in your gut where it
controls bowel movement its signals to
your gut but it's got food in it and it
should go on and do whatever it is that
it does to food and that seems to be
what it signals throughout your body
resource availability and for animals
with complex societies like ours
resources can be quite abstract social
resources as well as energetic ones that
your pyramidal cells respond excitedly
to serotonin suggests that we focus on
that which we believe will nourish us so
it's not collect correct as a blanket
statement to say that terminal neurons
respond excitedly to serotonin in fact
there's different kinds of serotonin
receptors and their binding tends to
have different effects so 5-htt one a
receptors tend to be somewhat inhibitory
5h d3 receptors are interesting in the
brain they're associated with sensations
of anxiety and queasiness and in the gut
they make it run backwards anti-nausea
drugs are commonly 5-htt three
antagonists now there's another kind of
serotonin receptor one that the
pyramidal cells in your brain find
particularly exciting
this is the 5-htt 2a receptor this is
the primary target for every known
psychedelic drug it is what enables our
brains to create psychedelic experiences
so you go to our show and you eat a
little piece of paper and that piece of
paper makes its way down to your stomach
where it dissolves releasing molecules
of lysergic acid diethylamide into your
gut now LSD doesn't bind to 5-htt 3a
receptors so if you feel butterflies in
your stomach it's likely just because
you're excited because you know what's
going to happen
and what's gonna happen is this LSD is
going to diffuse into your blood it has
no trouble acrossing the blood-brain
barrier because it's tiny but it's
powerful like you it will diffuse deep
into your brain we're into your visual
cortex work we'll find a pyramidal
neuron and find one of the HT 2a
receptors and lock into place once there
LSD stay is bound for around 221 minutes
it's four hours which is a very long
time in the land of binding and ligands
they think that this extracellular
protein el2
snaps in and forms a lid over top of it
trapping LSD inside which would help
explain why it's so very potent with
typical doses about a thousand times
less than other drugs so while it's
rattling around in there the little LSD
molecule is stimulating a feedback loop
in your visual cortex it is sending the
signal pay attention what you're looking
at is interesting it may be nourishing
and so the pattern finding machinery in
your brain starts to run overdrive and
at different rates in one moment the
pattern in a tapestry seems to extend
into the world beyond it and another
it's the trees that are growing and
breathing their perception of movement
of visual hypotheses that's been allowed
to grow wild with deep dream we asked
what would excite some layer of
Inception and then we adjusted the input
image in that direction now there's no
comparable gradient descent process in
the biological psychedelic experience
and that's because we're not looking at
an input image we're looking at the
output of the network we are the output
of the network the output of our visual
cortex is a signal carrying visual
perceptions these kind of proto qualia
that will be integrated by circuits
elsewhere in your brain into your next
moment of conscious experience now
inception never gets that far we never
even run it all the way it's the
classification stage we never ask it
what it sees in all
but we could in fact we can perform this
amplification process not on an
intermediate layer but on a final result
maybe we ask what would it take for you
to see this banana as a toaster or say
don't these two skiers kind of look like
a dog so these are adversarial examples
images that have been tuned to give
classifiers Frank hallucinations the
confident belief that they're seeing
something the just isn't there and
they're not completely wild these robot
delusions I mean that sticker really
really looks like a toaster and it is
very shiny and those skiers I mean okay
they like the body of the dog you can
kind of see it in the mountains and
their heads are kind of that guy's kind
of its tail it's okay it's it's pretty
tenuous but a person might might if
they're far away and they're tired and
they're high think that looking at those
two skiers they're seeing a big dog but
they probably would not conclude that
it's a big dog because there are current
properties of our visual cortex not to
mention the whole rest of our brains I
mean that our sense of the world is
stateful it is a continuously refined
hypothesis whose state is held by the
state of our neurons preparing us for
capsule networks
lissa sabor rates a parse tree is carved
out of a multi-layer neural network like
a sculpture is carved from rock so our
perceptions are this process of
continuous refinement which may point
the way to more robust recognition
architectures recurrent convolutional
neural networks that can ruminate upon
their input making better
classifications or at least providing a
signal that something is wrong there are
adversarial examples for the human
visual system after all we call them
optical illusions and they feel weird to
look at in this image we can feel our
sensory interpretation of the scene
flipping between three alternatives a
little box and
a big one a box in a corner and a box
missing one and in this monkey illusion
there's something scintillating
undeniably about the color of the dots
which of course are all the same so if
we design convolutional neural networks
with recurrence they could exhibit such
behavior as well which maybe it doesn't
sound like such a great thing like let's
make our image classifiers vacillating
an uncertain capable of oscillations but
it's our ability to hem and haw and
reconsider our own perceptions on many
levels that gives our perceptual system
such tremendous robustness paradoxically
being able to second-guess ourselves
allows us greater confidence in our
predictions we are doing science in
every moment the very cells of our brain
continuously refining a hypothesis about
the state of the world which gives us a
tremendous ability to adopt and operate
within an extreme range of circumstances
even when we're tripping face or while
we're asleep to dreams
these are not real people these are the
photos of fake celebrities dreamt up by
a generative adversarial Network a pair
of networks which are particularly
creative the networks get better through
continuous mutual refinement and it
works like this on the one side we have
the Creator this is a deep learning
network
not unlike inception but trained to run
in Reverse this network we feed with
noise literally a random vector of
numbers and it learns to generate images
but how does it learn it has no way to
learn in technical parlance it lacks a
gradient without another network without
the adversary the adversary is an image
classifier like Inception but trained on
only two classes real and fake it's job
is to distinguish the Craters forgery is
from true phases so this network we feed
with the ground truth with actual
examples of faces of actual celebrities
and the adversary learns and then we use
those results to Train the Creator if
it's forgeries go undetected it's doing
well but if they're caught we back
propagate the failure so that it can
learn now I should tell you the
technical terms for these networks are
the generator and discriminator I
changed them because names are important
and powerful and also meaningless they
don't change the structure of the
training methodology which is incredibly
powerful
this is a semi-supervised learning
technique because we haven't gone and
labeled every possible image or even a
subset of images that the generator
could generate and said this is
plausible this one is implausible that
would be a very difficult task instead
we have this process of recursive code
training in which two circuits play a
game ruminating on a space of
possibilities and learning to extract
maximum value from a relatively small
data set and this is a process that
might be helpful for neural sir
it's of all kinds though it does have
some pricks dens are not particularly
great at global structure this is a
fallout cow it has grown a cow with an
extra body just as you may have spent a
night wandering around a house that is
your house but with many extra rooms and
these networks are not really that great
at counting either this is a seven i
admonish you which is presumably now
count your fingers just to be sure and
if you find that you have more or fewer
than you expected please don't wake up
just yet because we're not quite done
another interesting facet of this
training methodology is that the
generator is being fed noise just
literally a vector of noise some point
in a high dimensional space so it learns
a mapping from that space onto its
generation target which in this case is
faces and if we take a point in that
space and just drag it around we get
this which is also pretty tricky you
know this this resembles the kinds of
things that I have seen that someone who
isn't me has seen on acid this resembles
the kinds of things that you may have
seen in a long forgotten dream now I
don't have a Magic School Bus voyage to
take us on to understand why that is but
I do have a theory when we see a face a
bunch of neurons in our brain light up
and begin resonating a signal which is
the feeling of seeing that particular
face taken together all of the neurons
implicated in face detection produce a
vector embedding a mapping from faces to
positions in some high dimensional space
oops
and as we drag around the generators
vector here so are we dragging around
our own a novel and unsettling sensation
so
a wild theory but it's not totally
without neurocognitive precedent so here
we have a rat in a cage we've hooked up
an electrode to a particular neuron in
the rat's brain and those pink dots are
the locations where it fires if we speed
it up slowly we will see a pattern start
to emerge so this neuron is a grid cell
so named because the Centers of its
firing fields produce a triangular grid
there's a lot of grid cells in your
brain each lining to a different grid
they seem to collect data from your
visual system and from head Direction
cells which similarly encode the
position of your head and together they
construct an encoding a vector embedding
of our position in 2d Euclidean space
this is operating even in our sleep if
earlier you discovered that you are
actually dreaming and you want to see
the end of this talk which you should
but you're having a bit of trouble
staying in it oh neuro knots recommend
spinning your body around your dream
body this is because your physical body
is not spinning and so it detaches
you're perceived body the one with 12
fingers and several extra bedrooms from
your physical one which is lying in bed
so this positioning system is something
which on some level you always knew
existed after all you know where you are
in space you have a sense of space as
you move through it and it's likely
necessary even if we believe the
cognition is computation that our
qualitative sense of space has some
neurocognitive precursor a signal in the
web that tells us where we're at in many
senses of the word part 3
sticks and stones they say you can't
tickle yourself because you know it's
coming
specifically when your brain sends an
action commands your muscles it's called
an efference when an efference is sent
your brain makes a copy it makes a copy
sounds very plan sort of engineered your
brain is this big evolved signal
processing mesh and so another way to
think of efference copies is as
reflections so we take that afferent and
send it to our peripheral nerves where
it will presumably make some muscles
contract meanwhile from the essence copy
we predict how our body's state is going
to change and then we use that to update
our brains model of her body estate if
we didn't do this then we would have to
wait for sense data to come back to tell
us what happened where exactly is my
hand right now
and then we faced the same problem is
trying to play a twitchy video game over
a crap connection signals take 10
milliseconds to travel from our brain to
our periphery and about 10 milliseconds
to travel back it's just not that low
latency or high bandwidth this nervous
system of ours and so to enable smooth
coordinated movements our brain has to
make predictions so let goes on but in a
moment we have a problem
because we still receive that sense data
from our nerves and didn't go anywhere
and if we update our models again then
they would actually fall out of sync and
so this signal you have to attenuate and
keep the model in sync this applies even
to our sense of touch when that touch is
an expected consequence of our own
movement this is obviously a really
complicated model an aspect of it are
likely distributed throughout our brain
but there is one place that is
particularly important in maintaining in
cerebellum the cerebellum is quite
special all action commands from the
brain to the body route through it
and all sensations from the body to the
brain as well it has long been
recognized as vitally important to motor
coordination like this people with
cerebellar damage have difficulty
performing this action smoothly so with
cerebellar damage our movements become
jerky and laggy it's been theorized that
the cerebellum acts as a Smith predictor
our brains controller for our latency
distant bodies able to estimate the
body's current state and integrate
sensory data to keep that model
up-to-date and decompose gross actions
generated elsewhere in the brain into a
continuously varying fine-tuned control
signal and once you've evolved it such a
thing has many uses and there's a
growing body of evidence implicating the
cerebellum in language which does make
sense uh pterence is a kind of movement
and language she said pacing and
gesticulating wildly is not limited to
utterance the work of moving words is
not so different from the work of moving
the body there are both transformations
from the source of internal states
efference and ideas to the external
world of sensations and world
coordinates and other people what
happens when this predictor encounters a
problem there's an irreconcilable
discontinuity in the model
these things are not so very different
they're visceral and guttural they shake
our bones and jokes too are shaped like
trauma
they're both shattering they're
illuminations of discontinuities
paradoxes which cannot be and yet
somehow are things which we must revisit
again and again our minds churning
trying to smooth the edges of cutting
stone the machinery of our brains trying
to make sense of a world that resists it
preparing this talk was a difficult time
for me I wasn't sure I could do it the
world appears to be falling apart I got
dumped which definitely didn't help
remember days when I would open my email
and every subject line would be a stone
and I would think to sew them onto my
dress and wade out into the sea but I
didn't because I remembered an I am a
process of creation I'm a song singing
myself
we are stories telling ourselves a fee
understanding itself the churning of our
waves creating every moment of exquisite
joy and every moment of exquisite
suffering and everything else it's you
you are everything everything you have
ever seen and every place you've ever
been and every song you have ever sung
every god you have ever prayed to and
every person you have ever loved and the
space between you and them and the Stars
and the sea is all in your head
thank you
you